[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he is the head coach at notre dame
i believe a former fifth round draft
pick of the chicago bears he's marcus
freeman back on the program
coach serious question to start out
how much are you benching these days
uh
i don't know i i do things for reps now
you know i don't know if i'm lifting for
a uh a peak number like i did when i'm
playing but um i like to rip out maybe
225 a couple times all right i like that
that's that's combine weight you know
the how many times can you do 225 what's
your all-time one rep
oh uh
it was close to 400 when i was in
college okay
the strongest player strongest player
you've ever been around
strongest player
james laurinitis might have been one uh
he was a a strong player um
trying to think he's the one off the top
of my head probably james
i'm talking about total bench squad
everything okay
uh what do you remember about that uh
2009 when you were drafted was it fifth
round by the bears
yep what do you remember remember
i remember being a long day um you know
and that's what i tell all these guys
that
you know i get a chance to coach that
have hopes of of getting drafted and i
say if you're not the first
overall draft pick you're waiting longer
than you would expect so
try to figure out something to do um i
remember waiting and waiting and but
when you get the phone call
it's a dream come true it doesn't matter
where you're drafted when you get a call
to say hey we're drafting you to
whatever team it is um it is definitely
a dream come true and you don't worry
about what that position was what was it
like when they told you
uh
bring us your playbook
it was a reality check you know and
that's the
is one of many
failures that that you have to overcome
and at some point no matter if it's
after year one or training camp one or
year 15 the nfl is going to retire you
because they don't want you anymore you
know a lot of people say they retire
from the nfl the majority of the time
the nfl retires you
all right let's uh get down to business
you open up with the ohio state when did
you start watching tape on ohio state
uh i would say sometime probably after
spring uh after our spring game when i
had a couple minutes to to watch him
film you know definitely would would put
him on but listen i've been watching
ohio state for many years just because
you know obviously i'm a fan
did you grow up an ohio state fan
i did i was from dayton ohio which is
about 45 minutes 50 minutes from
columbus ohio my my father was from
columbus ohio so i grew up in ohio state
fair
okay well that's going to be interesting
though playing the ohio state at ohio
state
yeah it will you know fortunate for me
i've been back there
on the visiting sideline uh probably two
or three years ago when i was at
cincinnati and uh you know so i don't
know where to go i know the locker room
what side of the field to go to so
at least i had that experience who came
up with the idea for the new uniform
reveal as you guys uh tapped into the
hangover
it was somebody in our fighting irish we
have this our own media department
called fighting irish media and uh
they're so creative and all of a sudden
i thought we were just going to vegas to
you know show some of our current
players the new jerseys and they said no
we're gonna we're gonna act out this
hangover the hangover parody and it was
a crazy experience you know as i tell
many people i didn't get into this
profession to act but um i think after
take two or three you start getting
frustrated and you just say acting is is
really just being how you really feel
and so uh it was uh it was a cool
experience for me and the players that's
good yeah it was fun and uh the uniforms
look great
uh what are the advantages of still
being an independent football team
well i think you you get to play a
schedule that that is truly coast to
coast um and and that's what makes us
unique and
you feel like you have a great
opportunity every year to make the
playoff as long as you win the the games
that you you have to win um and it gives
these young people exposure all over the
country and you play
great opponents every week how much say
will you have in the schedule moving
forward at notre dame
not much at all and uh
that's not really what i'm concerned
about you know i told our aed you let us
know who we're playing and we'll have
the team ready to go and so our athletic
director and our president father
jenkins have done an unbelievable job at
continuing to help this program um be at
the forefront of college football and of
athletics and so i i really rely on them
to
make those big decisions about
conferences and make those decisions
about opponents and those things and my
job and my focus is to get this team
ready
let's say your athletic director said
marcus what do you think about joining a
conference what do you think about
joining the big ten
what would you say
i would say is that what you feel is
best for our program and if he said yes
i would be in full support
that's a good thing to say smart man uh
how many teams should we have in the
playoffs they've they've talked about
you know different numbers here but uh
what do you think would be fair
equitable to the number of schools
playing football
i don't have an exact number but i would
say the more the better and the more
opportunities these college football
programs have to make the playoffs i
think it's better for college football
what role do you play in name image and
likeness at notre
dame to maximize it for our student
athletes and uh you know name image and
likeness is great for our current
players and and
i think notre dame offers them unique
opportunities to truly maximize it um in
terms of the brands that we're
associated with
um but but as i tell them all the time
the better football player you are the
more name image and likeness
opportunities you'll get and so
my focus is to continue to help them be
better football players and let our
name image and lightness team kind of
figure out those opportunities for them
isn't it strange though when you think
about
you know if i said when you're in
cincinnati hey you're going to be a head
coach at notre dame by the way you got
to you're going to deal with name image
and likeness
uh as part of your job
yeah that that's one of many things that
um
i wasn't expecting when i became the
head coach you know there's there's so
many different things that you learn
when you become the head coach at a
place like notre dame about what it
really means to be a head coach of a
place like this and name image and
likeness is one and academics is another
and and you know conference independence
is another but ultimately it comes down
to making sure that you give these young
people every opportunity you can to have
success and that's in name image
likeness that's in football that's in
development for the nfl and many other
things
is there any remnants of brian kelly in
your office there like is it a total
makeover
no no the the that's i'm sure is still
where coach kelly had it um
you know the pain is still the same way
[Laughter]
we didn't need to change too much any
pictures that are still up there with
coach
yeah there's picture coach around what
he's done for what he did for our
program was tremendous and we i don't
think you're doing notre dame or brian
kelly a
service if you try to erase him and
that's not what we want to do well you
know he sent me all of his coaching gear
really
yeah he sent me
he sent me his shower slippers it was
like a garage sale he sent me
some golf balls he sent me visors
you know we got pullovers and because i
said what are you going to do with it he
goes i don't know i'll send it to you
and he did sent me a whole box full of
uh notre dame gear
you know what that's awful nice to hear
man if you need more let me know we'll
send you some more
coach good to talk to you
can't wait for opening day against ohio
state thanks for joining us
all right dan thanks for having me
that's uh marcus freeman was it
cincinnati now he's already coached one
game
lost oklahoma
i think they lost by two
had a big lead lost oklahoma